لماذا تفشل فرنسا في افريقيا رغم تاريخها
الاستعماري الطويل لدول القاره في حين
تنجح روسيا في استقطاب قاده هذه الدول
ونسجي مصالح متبادله بينهم في سببين على
السياسه الفرنسيه وانسحابها من افريقيا
السبب الاولاني ان عندنا قيادات فرنسيه
منذ حوالي اربعين سنه
لا تامن
بالهويه الفرنسيه ولا تامن بالسياده
الفرنسيه ولا تامن بالقوه الاستراتيجيه
الفرنسيه خارج البلاد تاني شيء القيادات
الافريقيه ذات نفسها والقيادات البلاد
اللي كانت مستعمرها فرنسا
بتستخدم ريع الذاكره
الاستعماريه لتحاول ان تسيطر على شعوبها
وتشرح لشعوبها لماذا في تاخير في النمو
الافريقي ولماذا في فقره مستديم عندما
تتحدث وكان هذا الانسحاب الفرنسي هو
انسحاب طوعي وليس انسحابا طوعيا هو طرد
لفرنسا يعني ان الدول الافريقيه ضاقت زرعا
بهذا الوجود الفرنسي وتبحث عن بديل تجده
في روسيا ان كان لا يوجد اي استراتيجيه
تاثيريه ولا اي اراده ان فرنسا تمكس في
افريقيا فرنسا بتنساحب وطبعا اي شيء اي
بلد بتنسحب من قاره بيجي بدالها بلاد
تانيه يعني خلينا نكون واقعيين في فرنسا
لا تريد الخروج يعني على سبيل المثال
الاستخراج الذهب من بوركينا فاسو والالماس
كميات هائله هي الشركات الفرنسيه النيجر
على سبيل المثال يستخرج من الفرنسيين
اربعين بالمئه من اليورانيوم ويذهب الى
المفاعلات النوويه الفرنسيه مع ان النيجر
90% من النيجر ليس فيها كهرباء وفرنسا
فيزيائيا لا تستطيع السيطره على هذه الدول
لا بعدد الجنود ولا في الجيش ولا ايضا حتى
في الاسلحه ووضع الاقتصادي السيء نوعا ما
فيش حاجه اسمه سرقه فرنسا لما بتاخد
اليورانيوم من النيجر بتدفعه بسعر السوق
ما فيش حاجه اسمها سرقه كل ما بتاخده
فرنسا من الدول الافريقيه بتدفع سعره بسعر
السوق استعمار الفرنسي طارق منشات وترك
مستشفيات وترك طرق وطرف جامعات وطرق تعليم
وترك كثير من الادوات النمو الحديث لكن
التاثير الروسي الحديث والتاثير الصيني
الاقتصادي ده يعتبر استبدال استعمار فرنسي
باستعمار اخر ومش معنى ان روسيا بكره هتحل
محل فرنسا او الصين تحل محل فرنسا ده لا
يعني ان الدول الافريقيه ستختني وسايبين
لها سكه نمو بل بالعكس دول زي الصين واسال
الشعوب الافريقيه اللي بتستقبل استثمارات
صينيه وتستقبل جائلات استثماريه صينيه
اسالهم اذا كان هؤلاء الشعوب بيختنوا عن
وجود الصين وبكره والتاريخ وبيننا بكره
للشعوب دي ستفهم اذا في فرنسا انتحرت وحل
محالها دول زي روسيا او زي الصين بكره
الايام بيننا وبكره الشعوب دي هتندم اشد
الندم على هذا الاستبدال طيب ما رايك في
جورج ميلوني رئيس وزراء ايطاليا من حوالي
السنه صرحت بشكل رسمي وبخطاب لها ان فرنسا
تسرق النيجر باليورانيوم تسرق الذهب من
بوركينا فاسو فعليا هل هذا هذه فرنسا هل
روسيا بديل افضل يعني هل روسيا قلبها على
الدول الافريقيه روسيا لا تستعمل ولا
عمرها ما كانت دوله امبرياليه ولا
استعماريه ففعليا روسيا تقدم ما يسمى
امتلات لمملكات انا ما بنكر استاذي الكريم
اعطيني دوله كانت تستعمرها روسيا اعطوني
دوله واحده فقط فالروسيا تقدم الاستقلال
صديقي يعني جمعيه خيريه لانشاء الدول سيد
جون ما رايه اقول ان الراي ده غلط والراي
ده كاذب لان ما فيش ما فيش اي حد في
العالم ممكن يصدق ان دوله ممكن تعمل حاجه
بس عشان
التطرق لكلمه الكذب ما في داعي ارجو
الاحترام بتقول الكلام ده
بروباجندا روسيه لان كما قال الجنرال دو
جول دول لا ليست لها اصدقاء الدول لها
مصالح
وروسيا طبعا كانت دوله امبرياليه والاتحاد
السوفيتي كان دوله ان كانت دوله امبرياليه
وفي كوريا وفي الفيتنام وفي افريقيا كانت
دوله امبرياليه مثلها مثل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ده مفيش اي حد
مختلف عليه دون ان تسعى عن اي مصالح ودون
ان تسعى عن اي اهداف قوميه لها ده كلام
يعني سوري يعني كلام ساذ او كلام
بروفاجندا طبعا روسيا لها مصالح زي مثل ما
فرنسا لها مصالح مثل ما امريكا لها مصالح
روسيا لها مصالح روسيا تود ان تحل محل
فرنسا وتخلق لنفسها ساحه تاثيريه في
القاره الافريقي اذا كانت فرنسا تطرد من
الدول الافريقيه وروسيا تجد نفسها مرحبا
بها من قبل هذه الدول اين المشكله حتى
بمنطق المصالح الذي تتحدث عنه الا يحق
لروسيا ان تحتل محل فرنسا في هذه الدول
كلام ده غلط لان طبعا الشعوب الافريقيه
زرع في مخها منذ سنين ان كل ما هي تعيشه
من فقره ودين يرجع للاستعمار الفرنسي
فهناك يعني كراهيه مبنيه على كذب بالنسبه
للدور اللي بتلعبوا فرنسا في عدم نمو
افريقيا يعني فرنسا زرعت ما تعتبره خيرا
ما تعتبره شرا لكن في النهايه
لفرنسا جذور في هذه الدول يعني ما الذي
ستقدمه في المقابل روسيا
كوافد جديد اليها
روسيا تستطيع نرد الاستقلال الاستقلال
وتقوي الاستقوي السياده وتساعد الدوله على
السياده العسكريه والسياده الاقتصاديه
والسياده الاجتماعيه تستطيع الدوله ان
تنتج مشاهدين الكرماء لقناه الجزيره
بيكتشفوا الان ان هناك دوله بتحل محل بابا
نويل اسمها روسيا اذا سمعنا تحليل
الدكتوره افندي بروسيا بابا نويل
تصنع للخير دون ان تريد اي مصلحه اكيد
تبعت اخر اخر فيديو لرئيس الكونغو
الديمقراطيه وهو يقول يوجه ويمد اصابعه
ويقول للرئيس الفرنسي عاملونا باحترام
ربما هذا يلخص هذه النقمه الافريقيه تجاه
فرنسا ما رايك هذا الرساله ليست لمنويل
مكروكس الرساله اللي ارسلها رئيس الكونغو
ارسلها لشعبه عشان يوري لشعبه ان ان هو
يعني نوع من اللي بي ثوره على المستعمر
القديم الفرنسي اما بالنسبه للتاثيرات
الجديده سواء انها عسكريه او انها ماليه
دي تاثيرات وقتيه النهارده روسيا موجوده
بكره ممكن قياده فرنسيه اخرى واستراتيجيه
فرنسيه اخرى ترجع الى تاثير في افريقيا
وممكن تعتمد في ذات الوقت على الجذور
الثقافيه واللغويه الذي التي موجوده في
افريقيا والذي ما فيش اي دوله ممكن تمزعها
ابدا